d'où l'assiette merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france on le disait à
l'instant hier le ministre de la défense
marque espère s'est désolidarisé du
président américain sur la question du
déploiement de l'armée face aux émeutes
james mattis l'ancien général des
marines et ex secrétaire à la défense
donald trump est lui aussi sorti de son
habituelle réserve en accusant le
président américain de diviser les états
unis avec quel est le poids de ces
déclarations et que distel de la
situation on pourrait être rencontre
forte que les militaires s'opposent aux
les dérives autoritaires de présidente
rend donc 1,30 à fouiller dans les lois
et les trouver en 2008 107
imaginez c'est l'ère de napo lyon une
loi qui peut m'y autorise le président
d'ordonner les forces en mai contre ses
propres citoyens se tint loi pour la
rébellion pour l'insurrection et myspace
a bien dit ce ne sont pas les conditions
de maintenant donc ça c'est une très
bonne chose de voir qu'il ya toujours
les hommes adultes dans la chambre alors
le président vous lisiez américain a
donc menacèrent de recourir à l'armée
avant de se rétracter se présentant
comme le défenseur de la loi et de
l'ordre
cette posture du président américain
est-ce qu'elle a des soutiens dans le
pays où donald trump commence-t-il à
être seul contre tous oh oui donc il y a
soutiennent pour le discours de trente
premiers sons base c'est à dire les
hommes et les femmes plutôt blanche dans
les états de rouge pour laquelle les
noirs sont des symbôle de criminalité
dont certains dowie selon siffler pour
essien law and order veut dire
l'oppression raciale
mais c'est précisément contre laquelle
toutes ces manifestants sans fin
maintenant il a appelé il a lâché
c'est les gens avec les gaz lacrymogènes
pour une séance de photos comportant
tbib lalonde verts sont même prêts et ce
sont des problèmes d optique de
sacrilège de dérive de tyrans qu'ils ont
donnée les forces militaires et
finalement deux derniers optique il est
descendu dans le bunker de maisons
blanches aux types de l'acheter et les
choses d'un minima pour les autorités
acquis descendu dans le bon gars vous
parlez à l'accent à l'instant de cette
fameuse photo du président américain
avec la bible dans les mains comment ont
réagi les les autorités chrétiennes du
pays après la publication de ces photos
ans qui lie à 2 30 danse religieuses les
états unis en arrêt des défunts de
mentalist les gens de babil baird qui
l'ont soutenu parce qu'il soutient
soutiennent les présidentes pin's
parlement à cause de son opposition à
l'avortement mais les autorités de cette
église en question st john's church
épiscopalienne le évêques a constaté que
30 n'a pas prié qui l'a instrumentalisé
la religion pour les femmes politiques
ça c'était le sacre lige millions
divisions religieuses aux états unis qui
trompe joue très bien sur les faits
est-ce que donald trump pourrait
finalement sortir gagnant après ces
émeutes qui se coule les etats-unis en
faisant le pari de la majorité
silencieuse finalement intéressant on ne
voit pas un grand changement dans les
sondages
donc il est minoritaire nationalement
mais l'homme a davantage dans
l'électorat avec un 2 45% des dés dans
les sondages il peut être gagné
l'élection pour maintenant les questions
c'est dans quatre états qui ne sont pas
des cdu florine michigan plein sur des
miens et arizona
donc toutes les analyses près car très
franchement ces quatre étapes et pour
l'instant byden gains dans toutes les
quatre
donc oui ça pourrait jouer marque
reprend alors donald trump a également
déclaré c'était mardi soir un qu'aucun
président américain n'avait fait autant
pour la communauté afro américaine
depuis abraham lincoln
comment une telle phrase at elle été
perçue dans la communauté afro
américaine est ce qu'une partie d'entre
elle soutient donald trump hockey non
c'est mal perçu par le plus aux portes
des afro américains mais oui il y aller
que la voiture dans nos communautés les
gens qui voient dans le propre camp 13
de collaborer avec 30 mai nord
maintenant il ya collé un rage contre 30
c'est pour ça envoie ressentent un désir
plus d'une centaine dérive avec les
grandes manifestations avec les les
braquages les destructions les vins
nazisme en plus de les manifestations
pacifiques et en plus on a dit un soldat
rage culturel qui joue selon sa lettre
sur les médias dans nos communautés
noires donc ça ça joue très mal mais la
réalité c'est très peu de noirs votre
trempe
toutes ces actions doivent être perçues
dans un optique de réflexion et 30
il se débarrasse de noir il n'a aucune
entrée est de ne pas gagner le vote
pour conclure pour revenir à cette
affaire on le disait des règles chauvin
le policier qui a tué georges floyd lors
de son interpellation est donc désormais
inculpé d'homicide volontaire et non
plus d'homicide involontaire est la
pression de la rue at elle plus selon
vous avoir une incidence sur la décision
du procureur oui évidement ça a pris
plus d'une semaine des grandes
manifestations pour que des changes
semple affaire était ni contre le
policier en question
donc c'est un changement de 3e degré
deuxième degré et aussi un cocon
situation des ces officiers dans le
meurtre mais oui ça prouve que les
manifestations en fait ne montre ci
n'est pas seulement les élections mais
c'est aussi le droit des gens de
rassembler se rassembler pacifiquement
ou non pour faire une pétition de le
grève ce sont des cahiers de doléances
un peu et maintenant que les choses sont
faits j'imagine ans va diminuer ses
côtés ses manifestations
sauf qu'ils trompent continue à traîner
lassouts merci beaucoup douglas y est
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes professeur de
droit et spécialiste de sciences
politiques américaines